[موسيقى]
تاسست الجمعيه عام 1950
وهي الجمعيه الوحيده في الاردن التي تعنى
بشؤون المراه المسيحيه لهيك بتلاقينا احنا
اي مبادرات تدعم المراه المسيحيه وقضاياها
بندعمها زي مبادره محاميات نحو التغيير
انت شفتي قديش حاولنا نستقطب ناس يطلعوا
يحكوا بهالريبورتاج لكن للاسف بخافوا
يطلعوا يحكوا لانهم راح يتاذوا اجتماعيا
وكثير في حالات احنا بنسمع فيها وبيجونا
وبحكوا بالموضوع خاصه لما يكون في بنات
بالعائله بدخل عليهم مثلا اعمامهم ولاد
اعمامهم بيستفيدوا من ميراث الاب وفي كثير
قضايا منها اخر قضيه سمعناها انه السيده
وبناتها صاروا يدفعوا اجره المنزل اللي هو
لابوهم يدفعوا الاعمامهم هذا مثال كبير
جدا للي عم بصير عنا ولهيك احنا عم نطالب
بحق لكل مواطن اردني مسيحي انه يكون عنا
قانون كنسي ينصف المراه المسي موضوعنا هون
صار انه طب انا ليش اعطي حصتي مثلا لابن
عمي او اعطي حصتي لبنت عمي وهي رح تروح مع
شخص ثاني صفى الموضوع نفسه فانا ليش انحرم
ورده ابوي ليش ما انا انبسط فيها استمتع
فيها احافظ عليها احافظ على اسم ابوي زيي
زي اي شب يعني هلا صار ما في ما في فرق
والمشكله انه صرنا
بنعاني من هذه الظاهره ومنعاني من هاي
المشكله ما عم تتغير صار في مفاوضات على
الاراضي صار في حاولوا يوقعونا صاروا
يروحوا على منطقه معينه مسؤوله عن
العقارات هاي حتى يحاولوا يقيموا اسمنا من
الموضوع بحجه انه احنا مش موجودين او بحجه
انه احنا مسافرين طبعا
بيشتغلوا
بالدائره الاراضي كانوا كتير واعيين او
مارق عليهم كثير قصص كانوا يرفضوا يصير اي
اشي الا بحضور هدول الاشخاص اللي هم احنا